einer der heute polarisiert hat mit
seiner haltung ist der papst und das
thema hast du uns mitgebracht klaus o ja
wir mir war heute lange zeiten des tages
lange phasen des tages danach zu sagen
ein papst zuzurufen mein gott franziskus
weiler hat ein interview gegeben in dem
er tatsächlich darüber nachdenkt dass
die nato möglicherweise mit schuld daran
ist dass es zu dieser invasion von putin
in der ukraine kam und er hat außerdem
festgestellt dass er auf jeden fall
zuerst premier putin in moskau besuchen
wolle und erst danach vielleicht nach
kiew reist und da habe ich schon das
gefühl den papst ist womöglich in dieser
wichtigen internationalen krise ein
bisschen des navigationssystem
verrutscht weil es ja nicht nur auf den
ersten sondern auch auf dem zweiten
blick so aussieht als sei ihm die nähe
zum täter näher als die zu den opfern
als sei er sozusagen als politiker er
verpflichtet dem aggressor dem
völkermörder das schwert aus der hand zu
schlagen als sich schützend vor die
opfer zu stellen die angegriffenen dabei
wäre das möglicherweise das signal dass
er sein müsste als der große welt
diplomat warum nimmt der papst nicht
einfach jetzt seine sommerresidenz in
odessa oder in mario pohl und beendet
damit dieses furchtbare bombardement das
wäre gelebte nächstenliebe und nicht ein
waghalsiger diplomatischer drahtseilakt
ja es ist natürlich vollkommen
nachvollziehbar und los was du sagen was
du sagst aber würde er jetzt in
residence nehmen ihn in der ukraine wäre
das natürlich eine parteinahme und wenn
wir ich finde erst mal dieses signal
dass der papst sich als vermittler
einschalten will erst mal ist es ein
zeichen der hoffnung und wenn du ein
vermittler ist dann muss der vermittler
zumindest den anschein erwecken als
würde er auch die position der
gegenseite zu verstehen das vokabular
war etwas gewagt also von
vatikan pressesprecher
er sagte also eher sagte tatsächlich das
bellen also er macht er sagt eines der
faktoren die zu diesen eskalation
geführt haben könnten sei das bellen der
nato vor der tür russlands das vokabular
ist wie gesagt etwas bellen ist ist eine
falsche worte aber lassen sich ein
schritt zurück in marseille was wird man
aber lassen doch ein schritt zurück sind
ist es nicht so dass aus der sicht des
zerfallenden sowjetunion und später in
russland tatsächlich der westen die nato
die eu recht nahe an die grenzen
russlands geht aber ist nicht die hre
hatte uns verteidigungsbudgets richtig
also das ist ja ich will jetzt ich muss
immer ich möchte ich muss wirklich
aufpassen nicht als putin versteher
darzustellen aber ich mir als stürmerin
erzählt lieber eine persönliche
geschichte ist war 1991 war an bord der
fregatte rheinland pfalz urteil der als
wehrdienstleistender war an bord der
fregatte rheinland pfalz teil des der
nato mission im standing naval force
atlantic wir haben dort wir sind also
sein verband von nato schiffen briten
holländer
deutsche gibt es gemeinsame übungen die
in dem in der nordsee und ostsee
unternommen haben wir waren in einer
einer manöver nördlich von schottland
als die warschauer pakt aufgelöst wurde
1991 an dem tag als der warschauer pakt
aufgelöst wurde wurde diese über das
manöver unterbrochen und wir bekamen
befehl von der nato aus brüssel alle
schiffe sofort im ehemalige häfen der
das war des warschauer paktes an
anlaufen darunter petersburg darunter
italien um dort flagge zu zeigen die
signal war immer der der dem das
zerfallende sowjetunion zu zeigen die
nato ist hier und wir laufen ehemalige
ehemalige häfen und zwar noch sehr
interessant und wurde damals als wir so
nicht die häfen wie stockholm an land
gingen wurde und strengstens verboten in
uniform an land zu gehen weil die
wollten natürlich nicht dass grünen der
laufenden nato soldaten ein schlechtes
bild auf die bundeswehr auf die nato
werfen in den ehemaligen
warschauer-pakt-staaten gab's strikten
befehl wenn ihr durch die stadt geht
auch in eurer freizeit trägt uniform
damit jeder sieht dass ihr da sind und
ich muss ich muss sagen ich habe mir
damals schon gedacht ist ich war ich war
immer hardliner ich war immer franz
josef strauß ich war immer ein der
krieger ich fand ich fand auch gleich
noch grandios ich finde auch groß war
auch der der zerfall des warschauer
paktes war für mich als kalter krieger
eigentlich immer ein triumph für die
frage ist also was mit dem physiker was
macht es nicht und verliert bis man kann
immer gesagt es ist eher glory es ist
eine glorios zu besiegen aber es ist
nicht loriots den gegner zu demütigen
und ich habe mich damals gefragt ist es
ähnlich demütigung das sagen
touristische machte elite und auch teile
der russischen bevölkerung bis heute
nicht den abschied vom imperium verzogen
haben das kann man ihn aber nicht
ersparen genauso wenig wie man es
deutschland ersparen konnte wie man ist
frankreich oder großbritannien ersparen
konnte sich von iris material sei
geschickt es ist sich von ihren kollegen
doch das ist auch obama hat er recht
aber so ganz 1990 das ist der die charta
von paris die damals noch von
gorbatschow unterschrieben wo die dann
von russland übernommen wurde selbst die
nato osterweiterung wurde damals von
russland jagd und das polnische sich
erst die nato russland aktie nicht
gegeben also die einbeziehung
russlands in diesen
sicherheitsmechanismus und gar nicht zur
kirche noch mal zurückkommen wir sehen
auch gerade in ihrem hintergrund türe
welche rolle spielt
das ist russische staatskirche in ihrer
imperialen tradition ja das ist das
schulterschluss da muss man das auch
sagen da hatte die trennung vollzogen
also als war sehr sehr sehr weitreichend
messina von booten so dass es schon also
deswegen wundert mich ja dieses neue
ereignis um franziskus so weil da war
vollkommen klar und er hat auch am
anfang dieser invasion sich klar
geäußert und jetzt zieht er sich
offensichtlich mehr in der situation
eines diplomaten und politiker ist als
1000 tieren zu sprechen sind darum darf
der papst nicht versuchen mit putins hat
sich halt schon mal sagen das geht immer
damit los dass der papst sich ersparen
sollte dass er um ein gespräch bittet
dass der andere einfach nicht
stattfinden lässt bringt ja nicht
vermitteln wenn also sozusagen das ist
ja das ist ja quasi eine
machtdemonstration bevor irgendetwas
geschehen ist ich bitte dich um ein
abendessen und du sagst mit dir nicht
oder zumindest jetzt nicht das finde ich
könnte sich der
vorsteher und verantwortliche für 1,4
milliarden menschen auf der erde sparen
das zweite ist dass ich glaube dass der
papst als für mich immer das bild im
kopf dem aggressor sozusagen das schwert
aus der hand legen das risiko dass der
aggressor hier übrigens ein völkermörder
diese bilder benutzen wird für seine
propaganda den papst also quasi ein
spannend guckt mal wir sind gar nicht
sondern wir sind hier auf der grünen wir
das ist wirklich mehr auch durch den
kopf gehen wenn ich sozusagen wenn der
papst auf mich hören würde was für ein
schöner satz den der papst auf mich
wundert also da finde ich die die rolle
von franziskus wirklich 2 wir müssen
unsere ersten mal dankbar sein das ist
hoffnungszeichen gebe es eine solche
friedensmission angeboten wird wir
können doch nicht der logik bleiben
weiter weiter weiter eskalieren wer soll
denn sonst verloren wenn wir in einem
raubüberfall rufen sie da die polizei
oder rufen sie den priester wir haben es
ist ja aber wäre es dann nicht
sinnvoller dass sich der papst mit
kirill trifft
ich glaube zwischen den bayern gibt es
nicht viel zu ich glaube sie haben ja
sogar wenn ich das richtig heute gesehen
habe haben ja sogar vereinbart dass sie
sich besser nicht treffen weil sonst die
zerrüttung offenbar durch offenbar wird
das schiller kann man glaube ich also
sagen
diplomatischen parkett nicht nicht tun
aber es soll sozusagen
der geistliche führer eines einer so
großen teil eines so großen menschheit
mit einem völkermörder überhaupt
sprechen ist eine interessante frage es
gibt ja leute mit denen man gar nicht
spricht sondern denen man dinge zeigt
das wäre wieder diese das ist ja auch
eine demonstration der stärke
mein gefühl ist dass putin zudem
menschen oder soll ich sagen männer
schlag gehört die auch wirklich nur
signale der stärker verstehen da gibt es
noch ein punkt den ich noch dazu
anmerken möchte also natürlich kann man
versuchen zu vermitteln und dergleichen
aber eigentlich hat man sich als kirche
auf die seite der schwachen und der
armen und entrechteten zu stellen wenn
ich jetzt persönlich das mal so
formulieren darf und ich finde da geht
die katholische kirche jetzt mit dem
papst ganz vorne voran leider macht ihn
schlägt den weg ein wie die evangelische
kirche den auch hat teilweise hier in
deutschland wir haben ja sowohl der
pazifismus sozusagen wo dann einfach
gesagt wird ganz egal was hinten raus
kommt hauptsache keine waffen hängt dann
auch ein bisschen zu dem thema da vorne
dass wir vorher besprochen haben
zusammen es gibt da vielleicht auch
nicht immer so eindeutige ja nein fragen
aber ich finde als papst und ich finde
auch als katholische kirche und auch als
protestantische kirche als evangelische
in dem fall muss man eigentlich sehr
klar an der seite der ukraine stehen
moralisch weil diese verdammt wichtiger
als vermittler aus und ich habe mich
umgebe stehe
aber dennoch freue ich mich über das
signal eine friedensmission wir müssen
diese jede chance jetzt nutzen wir
können nicht einfach in dieser in dieser
logik der eskalation bleiben wir müssen
vor ort natürlich ist es eben putin
sprechen ist also bleibt man in dem bild
von geraten natürlich wenn man darauf
spekuliert dass der räuber den priester
sagt jetzt wo sie da sind dann bis mir
anders überlegt und ich gebe es ich gehe
nach hause geholt zurück wenn man darauf
setzt ich würde sagen mussten in der
vermitteln aber einer muss vermitteln
also es bebt bald darauf jedoch hoffen
müssen ist relation es wird doch fand es
doch nicht so dass ich verhandelt würde
es finden jetzt zwar keine ist am boden
finden gestalte stadt ja und online
finden also per video-konferenz die
ganze zeit gibt es konnten
gesprächskontakte zwischen der ukraine
und
russland es gibt ja auch nach wie vor
eine westliche diplomatie gegenüber ist
ja nicht so dass nicht gesprochen würde
das problem ist dass da komplett
unterschiedliche ziele und interessen
aufeinanderprallen
und solange putin die hoffnung haben
kann dass er durchkommt mit
militärischer gewalt wird er meines
erachtens sich nicht auf einen gerechten
frieden einlassen ein gerechter werden
nur die komplette integrität der der
grenzen von der ukraine ist natürlich
vollkommen unannehmbar dass einen das
minus nach lage der dinge so
unrealistisch aber man muss ja als der
zurück zum 23 februar zum status
auch auf deutschland